i don't what's the footprint of overcast
now i i i think you show how many paid
users you have on like the page with
who's paying
do you still do that um it's just like i
show like how many have upgraded this
week so it's never like a total
that is a a running number but what is
energy's
uh market share wise by libsyn's numbers
which i think are the most
broad numbers that are publicly released
anywhere um by lifting's numbers i have
um roughly like two and a half percent
market share of the podcast base which
sounds like a little and it is
percentage-wise a little
but it's actually one of the biggest
apps by having put you in the top ten
right for sure yeah i think i think
it's pushing like the top three actually
it's a top three on who you're
how you're ranking but yeah yeah i'm
very happy with it uh
and what is the uh and then the model is
i don't even know what i pay is it 50
bucks a year 30 bucks a year
not even so you it's free for almost any
use
uh but if you want to be able to turn
off the ads for podcasts
uh like i don't run ads for anything
else i run ads for other podcasts that
are just little visual banners in the
app
that you could if you want to get more
listeners to your show you can buy an ad
and overcast and promote your podcast
it's a native ad of course it's in a
podcast player um and so if you want to
turn off those ads as a listener you can
pay ten dollars a year
that's it it's only ten bucks a year i
feel like i'll pay 10 bucks a month for
it
and when i can if you want okay change
my subscription
um well i mean you just think about i
use podcasting apps at least an hour i
use your app at least an hour a day it's
always in my top three it's like twitter
my superhuman and then uh overcast are
my top three apps in my weekly report on
my iphone
when we left for the break i wanted to
know how you think about video
today uh and where that's going
are you seeing more of it do users want
it because i like people doing video
clips now
what do you think about video i think
it's a totally different thing
and it always has been and it always
will be
you know we right now we're doing a lot
of video stuff because a lot of people
are at home
um a lot of podcast listening did go
down
i think i saw i forget the exact numbers
but it was something like a 15 decline
um during the worst of the us quarantine
this past spring and then it slowly has
come back up again since then
to the point where now we're pretty much
at pre-quarantine levels of all of
almost all metrics i have
um but although that's scary in a
different way but anyway
yeah we uh for the most part i think
video has always been separate
uh and video podcasts have always been
something that you
create for different reasons and that
you consume in different places in
different contexts
one of the reasons why people love
podcasts audio podcasts
is that they can listen to them while
their
body is busy doing something their eyes
may be busy doing something
but that their their brain and their
ears can listen so you know
obviously the big biggest thing people
usually do listening to podcasts is
commuting
yeah or otherwise driving but also you
can like i listen all the time when i'm
walking my dog
or even just doing dishes or we can put
on a podcast while my wife and i are
having breakfast together and we can
just listen to a show together it's
there there's ways that you can play
podcasts while you are
otherwise like visual visibly occupied
like your eyes are occupied that is the
magic of it
right which has always been the magic of
you know like even howard stern or
back in the day other you know national
personalities
yeah it's in the background at work
people are working in a factory they're
working at their office they could have
it in the background maybe somebody gets
upset maybe somebody doesn't
uh but does that mean you would never
and because we have a video feed i think
it does pretty good
um do you think you'll ever support
video or do you support video now i
never noticed
i don't support video now and i don't
really plan to i mean unless things
really radically change i could
obviously reconsider but i
right now i don't i don't see the need
for it i i think i can make a i can make
a much
better app that is much more focused on
what it does well
by only doing audio because that's what
most people want on their podcast player
i think
all right so dan going over to you with
video i have recently
been investing in our youtube presence
uh
in fact like we're doing clips and we've
got 140 000 subscribers or something we
get a nice 10 20 30
000 video views each each episode and
you know obviously some of them break
out over time and
i'm thinking i'm going to keep investing
there because we do this to build deal
flow for my angel investing business
because i love doing it it's not really
a business as such as a standalone
business
what what is the what is the percentage
of advertisers who care about the video
component do they care at all
do video podcasts have an advantage over
audio only ones and what do you think
video plays into the future of all this
okay so long and short i think it's a
good idea for
content creators you know if i were
marco i'm not sure i'd do anything
different than what he's doing
um but if i'm you i would absolutely
uh you know i'm i'm big into omnichannel
i think that some of the most successful
shows that
that help advertisers grow and really
drive performance
are the ones that don't limit their
distribution possibilities
and so you know some of the best
performing shows that are out there
are simulcasts through everywhere that
people get podcasts but then also on
youtube
because if for the same reason that you
say you know rogan's gonna lose people
when he goes
to spotify people are partial to their
primary platform
and as such you're going to benefit from
being somewhere that
they like to get their content so it's
not that you're necessarily doing
something visually interesting
it's just that there's people that want
to consume it that way so give them what
they want